welcome to the session i am michael liu
from the chinese university of hong kong
the title of my talk is
an intelligent data driven paradigm
towards cloud reliability
we first introduce a background related
to cloud and cloud reliability then we
elaborate the following few tasks
in order to achieve cloud reliability
log analysis kpi analysis service
dependency and outage prediction
finally we summarize this talk
modern software systems provide various
services to our daily lives
in particular many such software systems
are hosted in cloud to provide their
services
cloud adoption by industry is constantly
arising and cloud revenue continue to
enjoy an impressive growth as predicted
in this forecast table to reach
354 billion by 2022
the most important infrastructure of
cloud computing is the data centers
around the world
data centers are huge hardware and
software systems with high-speed
interconnection networks the tremendous
complexity of data center operations
brings major reliability challenges
because many services are supported by
the data centers
if an outage occurs a large range of
users might be affected
for example according to lloyd's report
a major failure that brings cloud outage
for three to six days could result in a
total failure loss
of 19 billion revenue most of which will
not be covered by the insurance
to this end car resilience is very
crucial
state of the art called reliability
is motivated by service level agreement
with five to six nines of availability
and requires high degree of automation
unfortunately top failures
often occur to major cloud operators
cloud reliability issues are mainly due
to the fact that tough cloud failures
take a long time to mitigate manually
they improve
large
revenue loss
impulses on the company and harm
customer trust and company reputation
and it will affect everybody's daily
life
car failures are often software induced
or software related
traditionally software reliability
engineering or sre
aims to solve software reliability
challenges by providing simple
reliability models to track software
failures
my handbook of software reliability
engineering published 27 years ago
examined this process and introduced the
techniques to improve software
reliability including
for avoidance for removal
for tolerance and for prediction
this traditional analytical approach is
not enough for today's complicated cloud
software anymore
we need a new term called site
reliability engineering also abbreviated
as sre to tackle new reliability issues
of the cloud software the question is
how do we perform this new sre properly
we know data-driven ai techniques with
machine learning models
have been applied in many domains
this popular approach includes three
major dimensions
data models and paradigms and finally
tasks
in computer vision domain a
representative data set is imagenet with
many models and tasks
there are also nature language
processing domain and a code based
analytics domain with their own data
models and tasks
regarding data-driven ai ops for clouds
in our concern we should ask the
following question in these three
dimensions
in the data dimension we ask
what data to collect in the cloud
in the tasks dimension we ask
what tasks should be pursued for cloud
resilience and cloud reliability
finally we ask what models
and what are the paradigms
to serve various users cloud providers
provides the flexible infrastructure
containing three major layers which
generates heterogeneous data the
infrastructure includes application
layer
platform layers
and final data instead of infrastructure
layer
besides cloud providers
they provide customers service to
collect most incidents outages
as well as the
dissatisfaction from the users
they transfer feedback to the on-call
engineers
encore engineers inspect the status of
the cloud and discuss the problem as
well as a solution and this work process
will generate instant tickets
to gain more insights encore engineers
need more cloud status from the logs
from
the metadata
also from the topology
and finally the alert generated in the
cloud
they are collected in various cloud
layers as being shown here
so this will lead to our discussion of
ai ops for the cloud resilience which is
a data driven ai approach
we examine the following data sources
log data content application logs system
logs microsoft servers
microservice trace
metric data includes utilization of cpu
memory disk and network utilization as
well as the application kpis
the topology refers to the cloud
architecture of application layer
service layer and infrastructure layer
alerts are data generated by certain
rules
and finally incident tickets
include reports war room discussions and
chat messages
as we mentioned traditional sie employs
four tasks for avoidance
for removal for tolerance
for removal
and for prediction
for cloud resilience the four tasks are
roughly changed to
anomaly detection
failure diagnosis
root cause analysis and failure
prediction
in a nutshell data driven paradigm for
cloud resilience and cloud reliability
can employ five kinds of data to solve
four new si tasks automatically
as a result this slide highlights the
overall
picture of my talk
over various technical contents
including log analysis kpi analysis
service dependency incident management
and outage prediction
the presented techniques utilize data
resources from low level to high level
and the associate tasks is from easy to
hard
we begin with log analysis which enables
anomaly detection
we should first conduct log passing to
transform log
raw
data to a structured format
to do this
the log analysis ai cloud understand the
event
evident by
the lock
to perform a knowledge detection on the
lock a general framework is to first
apply feature engineering then trend a
model with features extracted
from the logs and finally infer
anomalies with the model
there are many log anomaly detection
methods following the same framework
most of these methods belong to
traditional machine learning algorithms
like clustering support vector machine
classification techniques and frequent
pattern mining algorithms
besides some papers discuss how to
utilize deep learning models to conduct
anomaly detection from the log sequence
this is an overview classification and
comparison of these methods in a survey
papers recently published
the next task is to use meter data
for anomaly detection which is termed
kpi
analysis an example
of metadata is kpi
which is one of the most important data
in the cloud
which is leveraged to monitor runtime
information of a machine like network
traffic response delay cpu usage so and
so forth
they can help us to understand health
status so we can conduct anomaly
detection over the kpis which may
reflect the real anomaly within the
system
for example a simple spike in cpu load
and network inflow may indicate some
anomalous status
they are typically
univate
kpis and multivariate kpis
the anomaly detection of these two kinds
of kpis differ
for univariate kpis each of the kpi is
used to monitor a specific component for
example cpu load
but these components are
coupled together which become
multivariate
kpis
in most cases there are fewer anomalies
when examining multivariate kpis and the
parts identify a screen are actually
normal
due to lack of manual labels
unsupervised anomaly detection is often
required
the intuition of anomaly detection is as
follows many machine learning based
anomaly detections follow the same
framework
it consists of two phases
in the beginning training phase we use
sliding window to generate data samples
for each sample we split the kpis to the
two parts
the
preceding observations in black
and the next observation denoted in blue
in the detection phase we compare the
difference between the prediction as
well as the ground truth if the
difference is obvious then the anomaly
is flagged
for example in real case only rare
combination of the states in different
category indicates anomaly such as a red
part
log and kpi can also be correlated to
enable failure diagnosis and problem
identification
different patterns with
within the log
may indicate different types of problems
but these problems may affect the kpis
in different ways
as a result we are able to first
classify the types of problems in the
logs and correlate them
with the degradation of the kpis
we evaluate the method on real azure
data
three large scale datasets were
investigated
our method called log 3c performed a
problem identification task with high
precision and recall comparing with sota
approaches
with topology information service
dependency
in the cloud allows root cause analysis
a production cloud performed many
may be built on multiple services when a
failure happens on a dependent service
cascading failures of other services may
happen
moreover when performing recovery
an awareness of the service dependency
may slow down the process
in public outage reported by aws we
found that 5 out of 13 aws outages are
related to service dependency
however current practice simply defines
the dependency as a binary relationship
that is dependency either exists or it
doesn't exist
but it fails to consider the degree of
dependency between services which is
caused by different fault tolerance
mechanism
hence we propose the concept of
aggregated intensity of dependency
and the normal framework is called aid
to measure that
it consists of three parts candidate
selection service status generation and
intensity evaluation
the input raw data is a trace log in
today's industrial practice calls
between services are generally recorded
by a tracing mechanism when a user sends
a request from outside the request will
be given a trace id
processing a request requires different
service collaboration each call between
different services will generate a span
lock as shown in the left figure here
each span will record the name of the
parent service
call duration call result and other
information
the right figure is a span generated by
an open source microservice benchmark
the first step is to generate candidate
call pairs
the purpose of this step is to find
all the core relationships that need to
be evaluated
one can complete this step by traversing
all the spams if there is a centralized
core database in the cloud system you
can also directly query the database in
the second step it is generated
by the service status sequence each
service has three types of status
indicators namely call times code
duration and error rate
and we can process them accordingly
based on the status sequence we can
measure the intensity by comparing the
similarity of the sequences
alert aggregation in aiops can also
enable failure diagnosis and root cause
analysis
to assist engineer in failure diagnosis
two tasks can be performed which are
alert aggregation and root cause
recommendation
as shown in this figure when service a
encounters a failure the failure may
propagate to its neighboring services
incident aggregation can separate these
incidents from other irrelevant ones as
the blue ones
so engineers only need to focus on the
red incidents which are the more
important ones to address these
challenges we propose an incident
management framework based on graph
representation learning as shown in this
figure our framework consists of four
steps
in the first step we detect the instant
bursts which often indicates the
occurrence of cloud failures
in the second step we use more
fine-grained cloud monitoring data that
is kpis to auto complete the graph which
recovers the big picture of the failure
next we leverage graph representation
learning to learn a vector of each
incident which encodes its interactions
with other incidents in temporal and
topological dimension
finally with the representation incident
aggregation and root cause
recommendation can be naturally
performed
the evaluation on real data set
generated by a top public cloud shows
our approach can achieve obvious
improvement compared with other methods
the ai of the application
the last one i will present here is the
outage prediction
where the alert data can be employed for
failure diagnosis and failure prediction
how components usually trigger some
alerts indicating anomaly behavior or
failure
but due to fault tolerance architecture
users are unaware of such alerts
so user may be happy when some instance
of failure occur in the cloud systems
however when the situation becomes worse
some severe fall may happen and the
cloud could become unavailable causing
cloud outages
to prevent such a cloud outage
this paper shown below here presents the
first detection
of some of the alerts and make
predictions on the possible outages
it utilizes a bayesian network in order
to keep track of the dependency for
example the website application outage
when detected is highly related to time
shifting storage testing and website
servicing so after data analysis and
augmentation from the bayesian network a
classification model can be trend to
link the
observed alerts to the cloud outages
and they got a very good result as this
uh shown in this table over here
so in this talk we introduce the task
list in the bottom for different goals
in order to achieve cloud reliability
which is actually an integrated
data-driven paradigm
so we can draw the following conclusion
data driven approaches are promising in
today's cloud intelligence and the ai
ops
cloud reliability as a result called for
new software reliability engineer
approach in order to apply data-driven
models and paradigms
and current approaches for reliable ai
ops are ad hoc specialized and
vertically integrated only
so i will recommend that more benchmark
data sets should be collected and this
will require collaboration among
industry and academia and i believe this
uh join uh working together is the
direction in order to make aiops
impact to our society
thank you for listening to this talk
you